you really exclude the PVV 100% definitively
the PVV excludes itself
in the way they are doing politics right now
you have seen me rock hard
for the rule of law
for how those parents were treated
but also the people on blacklists
I want constitutional COURT
so that those fundamental rights are better safeguarded
and later when I become a member of parliament
is the first thing to do
is the food or the vow
rely on the constitution
and that constitution contains the ban on censorship
and there is also
The Freedom of
speech and The Freedom of Religion in
as 1 other political party then
with 1 verkiezingsprogramma participates from no mosques
no Qurans
then you get fundamental rights
I can't go first
take the food or vow on the constitution that I do
who will defend and then say at the same time
and I don't do it on the back anymore
there it is and there it is
the the the real tension
Geert Wilders has 1 number of points in recent years
more right than
some parties want to say about migration
about the problems of radical Islam
but affect fundamental rights in this way
that is not possible
but if wilders says to you
you are actually absolutely right
I actually agree with you that
I change that so that it is acceptable to you
it is then 1 option for you
no we are not going to do that
it's in his verkiezingsprogramma
and he says it in
his DNA is then he shouldn't ask me
how he gonna change that
that's what he himself said yesterday
but just say the PVV with nrc
that is not going to happen
fundamental rights
with anyone
they are in good hands with us
why do you find it so difficult
than to say yes or no
because I always reason from the content
and everyone on the other side is constantly reasoning
with 1 quartet game
no but it is not a quartet game
this is just 1 question
you want with that party
so you start taking over
but rightly so you would say
yes me
we are not going to do that
no at the moment
they have with this verkiezingsprogramma
they affect fundamental rights
so they have decided that they cannot
that's what lies here
and if wilders still runs on it
then it is acceptable to you
then has it
then he should have had 1 other verkiezingsprogramma
and he doesn't
yes,
but the door doesn't seem completely closed yet
and
then he should have had 1 other verkiezingsprogramma
and he doesn't